[Music]
did you hear from Tom I did hear from
Tom of course yeah yeah he wanted to
know if I was okay and reached out of
course LuAnn de Lesseps opening up to et
about her December 2017 arrest for
allegations of disorderly intoxication
and battery on a law enforcement officer
are you nervous about what of Cour of
course I'm nervous I you know I I'm just
praying for a good outcome and and for
forgiveness and her current relationship
with ex-husband Tom D'Agostino whom she
split with in August 2017 after just
seven months of marriage where does that
stand kid you know toward you
Tom and I are cordial yeah you know but
we don't have children we weren't
together a long time so you know we're
we're cordial but you know he's doing
his thing and I'm doing mine do you
regret marrying him no I don't regret
marrying Tom at all you know I I loved
him I stood by him until I couldn't
stand by him anymore and that's when I
decided it was time to move on and I
don't regret it because it was a path I
had to go down I had to go down that
road 10th anniversary of New York
ten years like wow um what would you say
looking back over that ten years do you
have a biggest regret getting married
after you find somebody's cheated on you
is probably my biggest whatever why did
I do that exactly
think about you know that's why they say
love is blind that's true and my
daughter is so insightful she says mom
you know you had to do that so you could
learn from this mistake so that you
could you know be that much richer going
forward in your life you know in terms
of your next relationship do you date
again are you ready to date again I'm
you know I'm so not ready to date and I
said to my daughter yeah there's a go I
haven't kissed anybody in seven months
she's like mom really I just haven't
found anybody I really want to kiss you
no but I'm sure I will I'm just not
there yet maybe this summer yeah maybe
this summer do you think you'd ever get
married again you know I am a hopeless
romantic so I hope that I get me
again I'm in no rush but you never know
I'm an adventurous spirit and I live I
live my life with a lot of love and I'm
not afraid to love again so hopefully
that'll happen
[Music]